yes europeans who have opportunities themselves
what a party mini uncertainties on
problemfinding a job and the coronavirus
crysis makes it even more difficult for
them then i do support to take an active
role in our economy and society
the recovery plan die nu photos
next generation you as young  people a
hard rain's not only to meet you
stronger
greener en modu-tool wat weeks at
national governments to invest at least
20 trillion us to support you sentiment
this money shot finance the new
measures
let wie arlon ching to the first
wie een vos de european  youth guarantee
a free young person who signed up to use
county
sherif and good quality of there of jump
education at princip
op traineeship in just for one second
we propose to modernize vocational
education and training to make the
transition from cool to work smoezen
of the next  few who want to see more
than four out of 5 pages of book case
no education training and play
fruit of the boost and friendships
at alternat  ing between school and word
the franchise fiercely on the skills and
knowledge from florida looking for bass
measures will make it easier for young
people together job
use implement support is the policy
for the commission to support us
implement in these times of crisis we him
direct politics
mobilizing sufficient resources to offer
a free young woman and ever jang man
sallied opportunity to develop their
food potential
now is the time to provide for the next
generation